Finally we’ve made it.
For over at least the past 9 months we've
been on this amazing journey, like I think
I started Jujutsu Kaisen when I was around
the 30k mark which is truly insane to me that
we’re here now, so thank you for all the
growth with this series and others i've covered!
BUT YES for the first time here we are catching
upto the current happenings inside of the
unforgivable world that is Jujutsu Kaisen...
Its really funny to me cause every part in
this story seems to ‘in my eyes at least’
dwarf what happened previously and this section
of the story is no exception.
Infact in my eyes it sets up everything for
what I believe to be the final year of Jujutsu
Kaisen.
Especially if we stick with what Gege has
given us time frame wise.
BUT enough of me yarning about this amazing
series, if you are new around here then make
sure to subscribe and also push this video
to 5k likes and ill drop the full Jujutsu
Kaisen story (so far) kicking off where the
anime ended, next weekend.
Either way I hope you enjoy the video, now
lets get into it!
So!
remember how we left things with Yuji and
his group.
Well as the influx of American soldiers entered
the culling game a multitude of kogane’s
appeared and begin registering the soldiers
as new players.
Elsewhere, Kenjaku and Uraume are seen at
the Zenin clan’s warehouse, where surprisingly
its explained that there is a secret way to
transfer between colonies.
Simply they cannot leave unless they answered
the kogane’s call.
Unimpressed, Uraume instead suggested that
the space would be more suitable as the ‘bath’
for Sukuna’s revival.
Flying back over to the troops as they invade
Remi’s room, which is just the biggest L
for her ngl, in military fashion they throw
a flashbang before rushing in and trying to
immobilize her with a tazer allowing them
to easily inject her with a sedative.
Outside, groups of soldiers are seen remarking
that the sorcerers were nothing special and
simply wondered why their lieutenant was so
worried about the operation.
Rolling up, we see another group of soldiers
who’d taken out their target instead of
capturing them as ordered.
The soldier in-charge rebuked her, but the
latter flippantly said that it didn’t matter
since the brain was unharmed.
She further complained that literally nothing
worked against the sorcerer, and even a 50
calibre bullet didn’t pierce the target’s
skin.
So remember the helicopter dude Yuji absolutely
pummelled, well that's actually the person
her squad took out here.
Having heard the dude had a helicopter head,
the soldier was hesitant to believe her until
he saw just how damaged the females comrades
were.
In the end she concluded that there must be
sorcerers of various power levels and she
got stuck with some of the tougher ones.
WHICH AS WE KNOW IS JUST HILARIOUS.
THINKING HABA IS OP IS ACTUALLY TO GOOD, CANT
WAIT TILL THEY FIND A GRADED SORCERER.
Funnily enough we pop over and see the ruffian
Hazenoki exploding some poor unsuspecting
soldiers vehicle as they rolled by.
Noticing that the enemy was a foreigner, the
sorcerer remembered Reggie’s words and wondered
if this was the “bomb” he suspected Kenjaku
would drop.
Now back with the megalomaniac himself and
Uraume, the latter guessed that the cursed
energy of every colony could be increased
by pitting sorcerers against non-sorcerers,
ending the custom before the merger with Tengen.
Kenjaku admitted that what Uraume guessed
was only 60 percent of his plan, elaborating
that the cursed energy levels in every colony
except Tokyo and Sendai were still insufficient.
SO WHO ELSE ARE WE GONNA MEET, That's literally
Gege being like ‘well guys n gals there's
another 5 or so colonies that need to be kicked
up a notch.’
Also Kenjaku did only say that Tokyo was the
battle ground to the US, so im assuming they
aren't anywhere else other than there in Tokyo
colony 1 or 2 BUT we will find out later.
What's actually even funnier about the military
is that Kenjaku had only sent in the foreign
military as insurance and was already that
the fighting would not be very intense.
Having manifested a curse to clean up the
mess that was Ogi Zenin, Kenjaku claimed that,
unlike the reincarnated players, those who
had only recently awakened their cursed techniques
would be reluctant to fight and may even retreat
if they get to many casualties.
Uraume questioned if the military had been
sent in at night to give them an advantage
and also since non-Japanese individuals would
not release cursed energy.
Yet its actually revealed, that in the moment
of passing there’s an exception as the stress
of seeing curses pushes them to a new level.
Its also considered natural law that non-sorcerers
cant win against jujutsu sorcery.
As one poor poor American soldier notices
a terrifying cursed spirit, it further goes
in-depth that Kenjaku had released multiple
cursed spirits in every colony that are specifically
active only at night to force out that higher
level of cursed energy from these new soldiers.
Back over with our main crew, Angel quickly
deduced that Kenjaku had sent in non-sorcerers
to be killed by cursed spirits as a failsafe
to produce more cursed energy.
Having left the room and made their way down
some stairs, the group run into an empty cafeteria
right as a stun grenade lands in front of
them.
Noticing it, Yuji quickly kicks the flashbang
away before it could explode..
Seeing a squad pull up, Megumi initially assumed
that the soldiers were trying to protect people,
but instantly discarded the possibility as
the soldiers without a second thought began
shooting at the sorcerers.
Abruptly we see what seems to be a passed
memory from of a cursed spirit feeding three
young children inside an abandoned building.
Then back with the group we see good old Megumi
interrogating a Japanese soldier, who was
acting as a guide for the foreign military
forces.
When Hana asks why Japan had not taken the
opportunity to become energy self-sufficient
sooner, the soldier responds that the Jujutsu
HQ controlling the country is too proud and
everyone here is obsessed with self-responsibility,
so it would have never caught on with other
countries.
Megumi realized that Kenjaku had only lured
the military to the colonies under the false
pretence that cursed energy was up for grabs
as another energy source.
Megumi deducts that the soldiers’ deaths
would increase cursed energy in the colonies
and complete the ritual preceding Tengen’s
merger with the wider Japanese population.
Megumi is so damn big brain that the dude
even suspects that Kenjaku has likely orchestrated
the Culling Game as a distraction for his
true plan.
Stepping in Yuji asks if they should help
them, prompting Takaba to ask why they should
help the people who wanted to abduct them
for experiments.
Megumi reasons that if they allow Kenjaku
to fulfil the ritual, everyone would be caught
up in the merger with Tengen.
Yet, Angel cuts in telling them its no use
since Tokyo No.1 colony has already reached
the required level of cursed energy.
Yuji challenges the Angel’s decision, stating
that it did not invalidate their saving lives.
The latter explains that it has a symbiotic
relationship with its vessel, so putting Hana
at unnecessary risk is akin to putting the
curse living within her body at risk.
Shooting over we see the true terror some
soldiers are being put through.
After having fun with its first soldier, the
predatory curse picked up its next prey, which
just happens to be the Japanese soldier the
group was interrogating before.
Laying there and suspecting the worst, the
soldier thinks back to the times he had believed
that he was ready to pass on, but feels that
now, this is different and seeing what awaits
him truly shatters his resolve.
Nearby Yuji and Megumi just happen to be running
through an alley.
Megumi insists to his boy doesn't need to
be so hostile, and asks if Yuji’s comment
about not trusting Hana was a reference to
beings like Sukuna and Angel.
So referring back to that random flashback,
well it was actually Hana as a child.
Sadly she had been forced to live with the
cursed spirit for almost a year.
Eventually though she managed to escape after
following a white dog with a fluffy tail.
Of course it was no one other than Megumi’s
white divine dog who led her to safety before
returning to him and Gojo.
As Hana watches the 3 reunite and begin to
leave it flashes back to the present as she
remembers their kindness.
In turn she’s decided to try and help people
herself as she always believed that someday
they would meet again and she would proudly
stand by his side.
Back in the alley now, all Megumi wanted was
for Yuji to be a bit more considerate.
To which after hearing this, our boy confesses
that ever since they regrouped, he was scared
that Hana would take Nobara’s place.
WHICH OML WE ACTUALLY GOT SOME MORE NOBARA
CRUMBS, GEGE KNOWS WE ARE DAMN FEIGNS WANTING
ABSOLUTELY ANYTHING TO DO WITH HER OR GOJO.
As Megumi scolds Yuji and asks him to apologize
to Hana, the queen herself appears before
the boys, bringing the group fully back together.
LET THE RIPENING BEGING...
As huge beams of light emerge from every colony
throughout Japan, it begins attracting the
attention of everyone throughout the country.
Not understanding what's happening, many people
just note that something doesn't feel right,
like the air had become unnaturally dry.
returning to our crew, Maki gives everyone
a full rundown of everything that's happened
up until this point.
She explained that Choso had managed to protect
the back-gate of the Prison Realm, but relayed
the news of Yuki’s defeat and Tengen’s
capture.
In another location our boy Choso clutching
the back gate or literally hope itself, weeps
as Kirara asked him about Yuki’s whereabouts.
Pretty much to me at least confirming her
demise.
Maki further told the two first-years that
the ritual preceding the merger had ended,
leaving the boys shocked with just how much
has happened.
Calmly, Maki concluded that taking down the
villain would be a challenge, leading Yuji
to wonder why the merger hadn’t started
yet.
Angel points out to the group that sorcerers
could probably reject the merger with their
cursed energy, so because of that nothing
is going on around them; however it may be
a completely different case outside of the
colonies.
Being able to travel inside and out of the
barriers though Maki disagrees and informs
them that apart from a few affected people,
most of Japan population is unaffected as
of now.
Megumi suspected that Kenjaku either couldn’t
start the merger yet, or didn't want to; however,
since there was no way to find out, they decided
to focus on freeing Tsumiki first.
The big man himself, intervened listing off
the four rules they they had decided to implement.
Megumi again clarifies that rule one does
indeed subject a player to curse technique
removal or subsequently death thru something
messing with the brain, the purpose of this
first rule was just to start fights with people.
Maki remarked thought that it was actually
rules 2 and 3 which were tricky as they involved
somehow creating a form of movement and communication
across colonies.
Stepping forth herself, Hana declares that
she could move across the colonies by virtue
of the Angel’s cursed technique.
Maki asked if she could use the technique
on someone else to help them leave, but the
voice of Angel replied that they could only
extinguish a barrier technique by destroying
the root of the barrier itself.
If they cant locate the so called root, they’re
only able to pass through the colonies without
destroying it.
With the group realizing that adding new rules
might not allow them to move across colonies,
they decided to add the fourth rule and focus
on allowing players to withdraw from the game
entirely.
So earlier on and id say it was before they
left the Hotel, Yuta had transferred all the
accumulated points over to Megumi, bringing
his total number of points up to 359.
Btw this is actually a mess up by Gege here
but notice that it already says 1 rule?
well Gege messed up and spoiled everyone in
some way letting them know that INDEED Megumi
would create a rule!
Speaking up Megumi attempts to add a rule
allowing players to withdraw from the game,
but the Kogane rejected it, stating that it
clashed against rule 7.
Megumi tried again, asking if the rule would
allow players to withdraw if they invited
a substitute into the colony to take their
place.
BUT STILL Kogane refused, however out of nowhere
its states that the culling game has a suggestion.
It says it would indeed let players leave
the game on the condition they provided one
substitute and spent 100 points.
Unable to negotiate further and utterly peeved
with the result, Megumi agreed, despite knowing
that the new rule would require them to take
out at least another 20 sorcerers to just
leave.
With all of negotiations complete, Megumi
created a new rule.
Rule 11 - A player can leave the game by expending
100 points to invite a new player into the
colony as a substitute.
Looking over to the clan killer, Megumi asks
if its okay for her to transport Tsumiki to
the Tokyo No. 1 colony.
Yuji asked if it would be safer to transfer
the points to her remotely, since she was
already outside the colonies.
However, Megumi pointed out that since the
rules illicitly stated that a must declare
their participation in a colony within 19
days, trying to circumvent it might lead to
his sister being subject to curse technique
removal when she tries to leave the game.
Flashing forth to the fateful day of November
16 we see that after reconnecting with Tsumiki,
Maki led her and the assistant manager Ijichi
to to outskirts of Tokyo colony No.1.
So when it comes to who’s gonna be the substitute,
Ijichi had previously agreed to take the role
as due to Maki’s lack of cursed energy it
prevents the barriers from recognizing her
or allowing her to become a substitute.
Tsumiki is visibly conflicted by the idea,
but Ijichi reasoned that they didn't have
enough time to find someone else as its literally
been 16 days since everything begun only giving
her 3 days before she fully assimilates.
Standing there, Ijichi reminisces on past
memories and how he always wanted to be a
sorcerer that helped people.
Yet Gojo demanded he get his license and become
a manager.
Ijichi had thought the sorcerer to be harsh
back then, but now realized that he would
have been dead by now if he continues down
the path he’d previously chosen.
So remember the spawn glitch Yuji and Megumi
went thru along with everyone else, WELL SOMEHOW
Tsumiki hacked the game and got insanely lucky
abruptly appearing before Megumi and Yuji
upon entering the barrier, completely stunning
them.
With no time to lose in his eyes, Megumi transferred
a hundred points to his sister, asking her
to declare her withdrawal from the game...
However, to their shock, Tsumiki used the
points to instead add a new rule.
She immediately makes the 12th rule granting
players unrestricted entry and exit across
colony borders.
Mortified and literally just standing there
unable to fathom what happen Megumi asks his
grinning sister who in the world she really
was.
SO YESSS, DID I MENTION THIS WAS KENJAKU’s
WORLD?
Everyone just hold onto you’re damn seats,
there is a reason this set of chapters relates
directly back to episode 7…
Have you ever felt true pain???
In those few moments before what we now know
as true pain crawled its way out of the dark
abyss.
Yuji just assumed everything was sweet, now
Tsumiki was safe, Megumi would be all right,
Angel would follow up after and then kill
Sukuna along with Yuji and release Gojo, who
would in turn take care of Kenjaku.
The plan had no faults, apart from the fact
that they don't own the paying field.
Im honestly at the point right now that I
think they lose, this story ends on a sad
note and will be the first Shonen to do so
with all of the bad guys winning.
UNLESS YUJI GOES GOD MODE!
However, Tsumiki was then revealed to be an
imposter.
Watching this ‘thing’ Infront of him cackle,
Megumi asks the imposter who they are, to
which she hysterically gloat that she’s
defiantly his big sister.
Stricken and at a loss for words, Megumi remembers
that the Incarnated are given access to the
memories of their hosts so that they can survive
in the modern era.
Thus, it’s entirely possible for them to
impersonate their hosts.
Feeling like an utter idiot, Megumi berates
himself for ever thinking that his sister
had automatically awakened like Higuruma and
Takaba.
So the person inside of Megumi sister is actually
called “Yorozu”, a sorcerer from atleast
1000 years ago.
Megumi who wants to know why is told that
she just She pretended to be his sister to
use the free points for her own gain.
She hasn’t had a good fight in a thousand
years and wants to choose her battle along
with its location.
Claiming to want to take on Sukuna first,
moth-like wings begin forming on her back,
before she jumps off the building and begins
boosting away.
Yuji and Hana instantly go to give chase,
not wanting her to escape, however; like everyone
just remember back…
Already in a moment of despair, Sukuna uses
that opportunity to appear on his face and
utter the word “Enchain.”
As per the binding vow shown in chapter 11,
Yuji is instantly forced to hand over his
body to Sukuna.
Without any hesitation Sukuna immediately
appears on the back of Hana taking her out
with complete ease.
Looking over at Megumi, who’s brain must
be going thru it right now explains that he’d
once made a vow with Yuji.
Having explained that he cant harm anyone,
he notes that from here on out is just a complete
gamble.
Sending some form of channelling Cursed Energy
to Yuji’s finger, Sukuna then proceeds to
tear it off.
Screaming in pure joy Sukuna explains that
it was a gamble because he wasn't sure if
Yuji included himself in the vow when stipulating
the condition that Sukuna must not hurt anyone.
Megumi, Megumi, Megumi typical man.
Well dude honestly had no other choice here
so I cant blame him BUT As Megumi tries to
summon Mahoraga, Sukuna darts in grabbing
his face and restricting the summoning seal,
before shoving the finger down our boys unsuspecting
throat.
With cursed energy pulsing through Megumi,
an unconscious Yuji comes to not realizing
what's just happened as per the binding vows
stipulations.
However, standing opposite his boy he hears
Sukuna say they’d indeed see something interesting
in the future.
Raising his head we see that no one other
than the king of curses himself has supposedly
fully reincarnated himself inside of Megumi
Fushiguro’s body.
Well that just happened, and we very possibly
could've lost yet another of the original
trio.
YET in my eyes we cant lose them all unless
the bad guys win, so if down the line its
confirmed the bath completed then come back
and remind me that hope itself has been sucked
out.
Going back into that inner world of his, Sukuna
monologue’s about the intricacies of his
plan for Megumi.
Back during the day when he confronted Megumi
as Yuji for the first time, he sensed unmatched
potential from him, his cursed techniques
and his abilities.
He knew he could’ve forced Megumi to eat
a finger then and there that day but had purposefully
waited until he’d built up enough strength
inside of Yuji to initiate the vow.
I have a great theory on how well we all know
Kenjaku made Yuji specifically for Sukuna
WELL.
What if Kenjaku also made it a binding vow
that Yuji would not be able to use his CT
while Sukuna was ‘Caged’ inside of him.
With Sukuna finally leaving his body we may
see that Yuji has his mothers technique or
even possibly something else that relates
to a lil thing ill bring up right at the end
of the video.
Atop the building Meguna (Sukuna Megumi mix-up)
the absolute beast himself stands there leaving
Yuji stunned asking for his friend to talk
to him.
Yet and as we all probably expected was about
to happen, the demon, Megumi as Sukuna comes
in with a charge and punches Yuji.
Like this wasn't any ordinary level of punch,
MAN DISAPERATED THE FABRIC AROUND THE AREA
HE HIT, like it made freaking Yuji throw up
while sending him hurling through a multitude
of different sky scrapers.
Eventually Yuji ends up finishing his destructive
path on the rooftop of another building completely
unconscious and covered in rubble.
Noticing both Maki and Takaba approaching
the area, Sukuna states that in every damn
age INSECTS always come crawling out of the
wood-work.
Placing his hands together, Sukuna forms the
sign of Megumi’s ten shadows technique,
more specifically the hands signs for Nue…
INSTANTLY A MONOLITHIC SIZED NUE IS SUMMONED
ATOP A NEARBY SKY SCRAPER.
With everyone reacting in pure shock and awe
at the size of Nue, it release’s its usually
pretty ineffective attack that simply stuns
people, yet this time it rains deadly lightning
down on everyone below.
Having recovered from her previous beating
Hana makes her appearance showing up behind
the revived demon.
Seeing her, Sukuna realizes that Hana and
the Angel coexist and thus she can recover
very fast in comparison to say him and Yuji
in the past.
Given that Hana likes Megumi very much, she
screams in hesitation not wanting to hurt
Megumi; however, Angel insists that there
is no other choice, he is the disgraced one
and must be eliminated right away.
Thus, as Hana cries to get Megumi back, Angel
begins reciting the incarnation to dispell
evil itself.
SPEAKING TO GOD, SHE TELLS HIM TO PURIFY ALL,
REMOVE HIS ANGUISH TRANGRESIONS AND GULT TO
GUIDE HIM ON THE CORRECT PATH.
INSTANTLY “Jacob’s Ladder” Initiates
filling the skies with some form of holy symbol,
before a mass of pure light energy strikes
Sukuna down apon the disgraced one.
as Hana sobs and asking to get Megumi back.
In another note boys and after browsing the
interwebs i've discovered that Jacob’s Ladder
is referring to a line from genesis 28:10-19
which narrates the story of Jacob dreaming
of the angels descending from the heavens
and the ladder appearing to take the souls
from earth to heaven.
So in other words the attack simply dispels
evil while sending the persons soul on the
correct path.
Jacob’s ladder could also refer to something
as simple as the Optical Phenomenon made by
the sunlight striking the dust particles or
haze in the sky, BUT id say it more likely
has something to do with a God type figure.
INSTANTLY AS THE LIGHT BEARS DOWN ON MEGUNA,
it begins tearing at Sukuna’s soul in an
attempt to bring Megumi back.
As Hana is crying, screaming that Megumi belongs
to her it appears as if her technique has
actually managed to work, dispelling Sukuna’s
spirit from Megumi’s body.
But remember how incarnated sorcerers and
people like Sukuna can mimic how the body
used to behave.
Well Angel realizes that Sukuna is still in
control and is manipulating her with Megumi’s
voice.
Not paying attention though, Hana falls into
his arms, saying that she’s always…
Sadly though she’s unable to continue her
sentence as Sukuna full reveals himself before
going to strike down on an unsuspecting Hana.
Calling her a fooling human, Sukuna like a
rabid dog bites and tears at Hana before throwing
her across the building causing her to smash
into the side of the protective railing before
falling off.
Watching this in shock, not even able to actually
comprehend what just happened, Hana thuds
onto the ground below with no indication she’ll
ever return.
Looking down from the top of the building
himself Sukuna is astonished to see Yuji’s
somehow alive after the previous blow.
With rage filling up inside of him and if
we all the levels of cursed energy someone
can produce depends on their emotions, sorcerers
are taught to n this moment and after realizing
that he’s lost the one thing keeping him
together and giving him meaning in life, Yuji
Breaks.
In a flash Yuji jumps across the building
breaking the ground below him.
As he grabs Sukuna’s neck he SCREAMS his
name and lands a ferocious punch on the king
of curses forcing him to dart back across
the street.
Regaining his footing, Sukuna wonders just
how in the world he’s so strong, then in
that freaking moment Yuji takes him off-guard
throwing a massive section of the previously
collapsing building into the demons face,
sending him shooting back once again.
Sprinting towards them himself, Yuji grabs
a piece of rebar to beat him down.
With him darting in behind, Sukuna remarks
that he should've seen this coming, after
all Yuji is from ‘back then’.
What ya mean by that Sukuna??
ae ae?
Having blocked Yuji’s strike with the bar,
Sukuna counters by disarming and kicking him
in the face while noting that Kenjaku sure
is twisted.
(ill expand more on what this means in a moment,
but honestly in my opinion this all relates
back to Yuji and him being suppressed or his
CT being suppressed while he was being used
as a ‘cage’ for Sukuna.
So don't be surprised if our guy manages to
manifest an inherited technique in the near
future).
As Yuji continues to approach Sukuna trying
to attack him, he screams wondering why, why
is it that he cant just live normally like
everyone else.
WHY CANT HE LIVE A LIFE WITHOUT CAUSING EVERYONE
TO SUFFER…
He continues to approaches, when all of a
sudden Sukuna uses his cursed technique; slash,
to cut Yuji.
Replying to his statements, Sukuna rebuttals
to him asking why he’s so weak, continuously
trying to cling to life.
He continues by saying that their suffering
is only natural and they are meant to live
with this misery.
For a moment Yuji forgot that there is no
reasoning with them, as they are always and
will always be “Curses”.
Yuji dares Sukuna to chew on his misery him
and suffering, while beginning his march towards
the demon lord himself.
Passing him off as pathetic Sukuna uses his
cured technique to continuously cut Yuji over
and over and over and over.
YET OUR BOY IS BUILT DIFFERENT AND WITH A
RAGE FILLED HEART, HE PUTS THE PAIN ASIDE
AND STUNS SUKUNA BY NOT SLOWING HIS APPROACH
AT ALL…
Standing there and actually confused now,
Sukuna wonders how in the world is he so tough.
Then out of freaking no where and just like
during Shibuya, once again proving that the
body and soul are one, MEGUMI HALTS SUKUNA
allowing his boy to follow up and pummel his
face with a fat right hook.
Else where and literally boosting it over
on the blowfish express, Uraume and Kenjaku
are seen travelling towards what I assume
to be the current beatdown.
Back in the battle and having smacked Sukuna
in the face, Meguna remarks that Fushiguro
is indeed stopping his cursed energy output
which is allowing him only to use 10% of his
maximum amount, hence how Yuji has managed
to survived the blows so far.
Sukuna notes that's well its probably expected
when the jobs only half done, but still considers
it enough to easily take out Yuji.
Interesting, so I wonder what this other half
of the ritual to fully take over Megumi’s
body will be.
We know its something called the ‘bath’
and it’ll happen at the Zenin household,
which is fitting seeing that Megumi is really
from that families blood line.
Im suspecting that it probably has something
to do with Megumi’s domain expansion and
that huge vertebrae bone that was floating
there.
Standing there Meguna is completely take by
surprise as he couldn't sense Maki slowly
moving towards the epicentre of the fight.
Wanting to know what in the world caused Sukuna
to body switch, Maki asks to be brought upto
date with Yuji completely battered just telling
her to kill him as he’s not gonna die either
way…
Boosting in, Maki attempts to land a fat head
kick in combination with Yuji; however, Megumi’s
body is functioning extremely well (obviously
from what we’ve just seen), and he’s comfortably
able to counter his opponents.
Still, Maki cause she’s built kinda different
is able to break through his defences and
sends him flying smashing into some railing
nearby.
Taking the opportunity, Yuji grabs the other
side of the railing bending it around Sukuna,
before Maki follows up in combination and
kicks him into a building.
Seeing the unharmed demon waltz out, Maki
wonders if its impossible to actually inflict
damage with her soul liberation sword because
Sukuna will his reversed cursed techniques
to heal himself.
Again, with Sukuna being the most proficient
RTC user, you cannot be surprised with how
capable he is at healing anything, he may
even know how to repair souls thru RTC.
Knowing that no matter what happens here,
they have to kill Sukuna, Maki charges in
saying he’ll have to keep up with her speed.
Probably running at speeds faster than sound,
Sukuna is able to keep up with the attacks
of Maki and Yuji but notes that whenever he
tries to attack them with cursed energy, the
pull from Megumi inside is stronger, and thus
to try get around Megumi Sukuna uses his cursed
technique; Cleave: Spider Threads.
on the ground to utterly destroy it and disbalance
Yuji and Maki.
With the ground falling to bits around them,
Sukuna is able to dart in and land a fat right
hook.
Yet as Maki spits out a tooth or 2, he’s
left impressed that she’s hardly even worried
with taking damage.
As Sukuna falls back a little, a mysterious
foe randomly appears from the side and uses
a maximum output technique called DEAD CALM.
The resulting aftermath from the attack not
only freeze’s the entirety of the area but
also Maki and Yuji..
So that mysterious person just happened to
be the coldest person out, Sukuna’s right
hand woman, Uraume, who apologizes for her
grand entrance saying that she weekend the
ice around Yuji just in case.
Sukuna though literally does not care for
him anymore and instead just complements her
stating that focusing her energy on Maki was
a good idea.
Believing that everything is sweet here, Sukuna
then summons a Nue, saying that this body
is not still complete, so they need to prepare
the bath immediately.
asks her to prepare the bath.
Uraume insists that the bath is ready and
they must hurry.
To which its revealed that the bath is indeed
prepared, so its time to go!
In that moment though, our goat looking more
beaten and bruised than ever after this escalade,
bursts his way out of the ice.
Noticing this Uraume proposes taking him out,
Sukuna says that they should look at him and
just have a good laugh.
Flying away for good, Sukuna as Yuji’s best
friend and Uraume laugh at Yuji’s face noting
that his face looks just like that person
from the Harima province…
WHICH is what I was referring to before and
goes back to Kenjaku using a binding vow on
using Yuji at birth or even before.
We know he purposefully found a bloodline
that has some form of durability, possibly
to keep Sukuna safe during his time in Yuji,
and now its confirmed that Yuji’s true heritage
originates from a family in the Harima province.
This Harima province was established in the
600s AD and ran upto the late 1800’s before
it merged into a bunch of different districts.
So im assuming he’s from a time before the
golden age of sorcery and could've even been
an old family in the Jujutsu would that used
to be a top contender but supposedly died
out over the ages.
Ya thought the arc ended here??
no no no, Sukuna as Megumi speed run this
damn bath and after having arrived at the
Zenin’s household we see him falling deeper
and deeper into evil itself.
Outside the bath Uraume dressed up ritual
robes asks Kenjaku whether or not he plans
to end the culling game.
To which its explains that his assimilation
of the wider population cant actually happen
until the game ends.
The reason the culling game was even able
to be constructed in the first place was because
Kenjaku had shouldered the burden of an equally
unreasonable binding vow.
Yet instead of getting on with ending it,
currently, he’s more interested in Sukuna’s
“bath” and its workings.
Kenjaku himself knew that The ‘bath’ was
originally a ritual to transform vessels that
had been treasured as family heirlooms into
cursed tools.
To do this the clan must make a solution of
cursed energy which is created by straining
organisms chosen in a Kodoku ritual.
Once that is prepared the vessels are soaked
for 10 months and 10 days in the solution.
So what's really cool about this Ritual is
that its actually something from real Japanese
folklore.
Its a derivative of the Chinese Gu magic and
is a type of poisons ability.
In reality To create Kodoku, sorcerers would
mix several insects in a jar, and let them
kill one another until only one survived.
The fluids of the insect that survived would
be used to poison an individual with a curse
that would control them, cause them misfortune,
or kill them.
The remaining insect could also be used as
a sort of "luck charm" granting the one who
performed the ritual great wealth.
This ritual could also be used as a death
curse by giving the riches to an ignorant
individual.
(perhaps Kenjaku is the ignorant one here)
The term "Kodoku" can also be applied to the
spirit which is the incarnation of this particular
magic.
Funnily enough, the technique was used in
the Nara Period, which is as we know the era
just before the golden age of Jujutsu Sorcery.
Kenjaku was actually surprised that they specifically
chose curses, especially for the fact that
the become dust apon their deaths.
Uraume though, like the cold queen she is
figured out a way around this.
Simply if she carefully pins down the spirits
before freezing theirs cores, they don't turn
to dust and it allows them to strain away
the toxins they need.
Confused with the purpose of it all, Kenjaku
asks why and Uraume just tells him its to
get closer to evil.
The entire purpose of this ritual is to suppress
Megumi Fushiguro’s soul deeper into the
depths.
As the further down he sinks the easier it
is for Sukuna to control the cage he’s currently
controlling.
Having completed the bath, the Demon Lord
himself rises from the depths of evil, symbolizing
that Megumi Fushiguro has lost the small hold
he had over Sukuna!
Kenjaku questions why he didnt change his
appearance, but Sukuna just reasons that if
he’s gonna be battling sorcerers then its
better to maintain Megumi’s appearance.
Honestly this is probably for the fact that
whenever he runs into a group of people from
Jujutsu High itl just shatter their resolve,
as they never suspected something like this
would ever happen.
So remember Tsumiki, now Yoruzu, well it was
a dude that reincarnated inside of her and
after leaving Yuji they’d travelled back
to their home town before later heading to
Sendai colony which was the closest colony
to it.
Having got the run down on this from Kenjaku,
Sukuna says he doesn’t gives a damn about
Yorozu but instead wants to destroy Tsumiki
Fushiguro, to completely sink Megumi Fushiguro
inside him.
As they then leave on the blowfish express,
Kenjaku tells him that he’ll give him a
ride but wants the points in exchange.
So I truly wonder what in the world he’s
about to do with the 200 or so points he just
received.
Let me know your thoughts down below!
Shooting back to Sendai colony for the first
time in a while both Uro & Ryu notices a mass
of bloodlust appear from afar.
Uro utterly breaks down muttering, “Here
he comes, THE KING OF CURSES!!”
Instantly Sukuna arrives infront of Ryu and
as he slowly begins walking upto him, he asks
if he’s gonna run or not.
But before Ryu could even act, Sukuna activates
his Slash technique and slashes Ryu across
the chest.
Blown away though that he wasnt cut into a
multitude of pieces, Sukuna just laughs and
apologizes saying he underestimated Ryu by
wont hold back again...
Feeling the bloodlust rising, Uro jumps back
& tries to use Granite Blast but before he
could even finish his attack sequence, Sukuna
slices Ryu across the face utterly destroying
one of my favorite characters in typical Gege
fashion!!
Having left the area and arrived at a football
field in Sendai after 1000 years SUKUNA ENCOUNTERS
YOROZU.
After realizing he’s stolen someone elses
body and switched Sukuna just remarks that
this dudes face looks much better!
AND DAMN I GOT COVID So I really hope my voice
held up here guys, but what a way to revive
the KING OF CURSES HIMSELF.
Obviously from what we can see he isn't fully
revived yet and has chosen to just keep the
form of Megumi until he can completely subdue
the students soul.
Id love to know what your thoughts are on
this arc so make sure to let me know down
below and and if you are new around here and
want to watch more content just like this
but for a bunch of different series, then
make sure to subscribe with that bell noti
on.
Also ill be re-scripting and editing the Gojo
past arc over the next few days for the full
jjk story video so for all my long time subscribers
it feels like a new video in a way with updated
effects etc!
So if you do want early access to that then
check out my Patreon and also i've had a few
comments asking for this in podcast format.
SO i've gone done that if your interested
aswell and all the links for that are in the
description BUT anyway for now's been ya professional
degenerate Diavolo and ill see you all in
a bit.
BYE!!